What does it look like
tan
honor and pride
[music]
[applause]
power and power
money and treasure
welfare
or
something that transcends all of these
What do you wish for and look into the distance at the risk of your life I
[music]  ]
No matter what mode you
do, it's here  If you
want to see the stars and climb the tower for a
while If you have a girl like that, you don't need
anything, right?
I did
[music]
[music] my
friend eh
[music]
me
which one is fun
?
[Music] [Music]
[Applause] It was just
pa The
answer is always on top of my head
[Music] A
quiet guest  I'm also impressed
I'm Heddon I'm
the manager of this
kind
of thing Baht
[music]
Peach
Here's
this Inoo I'm worried about this acquaintance
Good night boy why
my mom  That's what I call that
face!
Yeah, I'll go inside the moat,
avoid the strong white trees, and if I finish that ball, I'll pass
Will you take the test?
Haa
oops pai
[applause]
hm [music] Also, if it's a hole, it's probably a
baited amairo a I
had 7 roofs, but I was inside.
Hey, luxury pockets that don't suit your level 4 pockets Lifestyle for long trips that's not just automatic translation  I'm
going to go into my pocket and say hikashi mode and everyone will take a
photo  A stranger who came is a
fusion t You seem to be weak even though you're a completely different person What are you going to do?
Even if this place is onishi,
go ahead and move on.
Until I do it
Ah, why are you doing this kind of test?
That super eel covered in steel scales, even if it's a level 20, it's a monster with 4 swings
.  I can feel the
sudden transformation, doesn't it look chic with perilla vinegar?
That's what
Cora Evan says, too.  I don't
know who you are, but thank you for your kindness. I do
n't even know the princess of the hard.
I'm trying to climb the head in such a human state I
want to die I want
to give up here It's a town Oh,
if you want him to climb that far, Mr.
Yuri,
why don't you lend me the Black March
?  There is no mate that can be transmitted to the hard, even if it is a lump of mass, it can be a blade that cuts through everything.The
Black March is only allowed to be held by the princess of
zard.  Wow,
I'll lend it to you You have a cute face, so it's fine
Sanma,
you're amazing, you want to climb the tower
First of all, don't you think only about protecting your own life
?
boring
[Applause]
Actually, there's only one way to pass this test
[Music] If you help
ah ah ah ah
, you'll be disqualified So let's leave
it alone That's the path he chose
It's a good thing
Shut up and take it with you, girl, even if it's for management.
Overcoming fear over death is the answer to this test.
I can't do it,
but I can't deal with it Even if there is, it
's something that can overcome the fear of death
.
What's going on, why won't the ball break
?  Wait, now
I'm over there
[music] Then you
don't
remember
anything
That's scary, isn't it?
For the chief award, the
sky spreads out
and countless beautiful stars are shining.
Haha, in
such a dark world, that's the way to go 0 It's
a bit of a mess l Petri dish
r
Looks like I made a little too much noise
Don't you think that sword is a character
?
I'm sorry,
but
[music]
It's different because of my face.
The
superstition in my head is true Sakura
[music]
I'm not
going to go natto I'm not going to go to the
next episode Air
What are you going to do with that guy?  But if you keep the Black March, you should go get it back, right?
That's about
it, get to work
right now Wait for a few turns It was a pretty interesting event right now yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
What will happen from now on?
The flower I met again
is a girl who lived a time you don't know
[music]
No nurse
, the road ahead is steep
[music]
Checkers,
microphone test
Welcome,
this is where you decide if you are worthy of being on the street at the
fest party
Shall we start testing cars first? The
rules are simple
.
The number of guests is about approx. The
guests are finished
. You can check the remaining needs of the sorters and the elapsed time in your pocket.
]
[Applause]
ana
voodoo
It's no use running away
.  It's about time, yeah, yeah, boom Hey
, what are
you trying to kill me?  In
order to survive, I have
no choice but to climb my head
[Music]
What are
you doing?  Yeah, I
wonder what this ki is,
this lizard air,
this weapon area,
this is also a
great weapon
eater  I got it
[music] I
'm sorry, I can't, I can't,
I
can't catch such a lazy rabbit
[Applause]
If you're going to point your sword at the back, don't you
ah ah ah
[music]
Recommended
pandan
Dabo-dabo
[music]
manen  Yororabe Toride If I remember, I'm dead on my feet
North I
feel good alone, so I don't want to fall on my knees So I'm
here with the black bada
me
ha 1 rar
[music]
ah ah ah